[Music]
I'd say one of the most disappointing
GPU releases of the last few
generations, excluding the GeForce 50
series, of course, was Nvidia's GeForce
RTX 4060 series. And that included the
RTX 4060, 4060 Ti 8 GB, and then the
4060 Ti 16 GB. All of them were pretty
bad, but it was the 8 GB models that
were particularly atrocious for a mid
2023 release, especially given the
asking price and then of course the
resulting performance. Of course though,
we are talking about GeForce GPUs here,
so they did sell quite well. And despite
offering very little over their
predecessors, their success in no small
part can be attributed to the fact that
there was no real competition. AMD's
Radeon
RX7600 that was really equally bad. So,
I think pointing to the Steam hardware
survey as some kind of evidence that the
RTX 4060 doesn't or didn't suck does
miss the point a bit because
realistically, when you have the choice
between uh a turd sandwich and a turd
sandwich, you can't really blame gamers
all that much for buying a turd
sandwich. Today's sponsor spot is
brought to you by Hetsnut, one of
Europe's top hosting providers and data
center operators with their locations in
Germany, Finland, the USA, and
Singapore. Trusted since 1997 for
powerful infrastructure, great pricing,
and rocksolid support. With the US cloud
act able to force any American company
to share your data. Choosing a German
hosting provider like Hznner ensures
that your data is not only protected by
the GDPR but also benefits from the
comprehensive security requirements of
German data privacy laws. With a
European cloud provider such as HTNA
cloud, your data is not only GDPR
compliant, but can also be easily scaled
at any time to suit your needs flexibly
and securely. For more information on
Hetsner and the service they offer,
please click the link in the video
description. As underwhelming as the RTX
4060 was at $300 US with its pitily 8 GB
frame buffer, the RTX 4060Ti was much
worse in my opinion. Yeah, it was a fair
bit faster, but at $400, it was still
limited to just 8 GB of VRAM, which
again in my opinion was highly
questionable back in 2023. And worse
still, the 16 GB version, which shared
the same name, that costs an additional
$100 US upon release, making the
cheapest GeForce GPU worth buying an
eyewatering $500 US. Since then, we've
been well and truly vindicated. The push
back against our claims that the 8 GB
4060Ti would age poorly and wasn't worth
buying was pretty extreme at the time,
but today it seems like just about
everyone is on the same page. Well,
everyone of course except for Nvidia. I
say this because in the year 2025,
Nvidia is releasing a new GeForce 50
series GPU with just 8 GB of VRAM. In
fact, not just one model, but rather
two. So, in other words, this is a
repeat of the GeForce 40 series with the
5060 exclusively using 8 GB of VRAM. And
there'll also be an 8 and 16 GB version
of the 5060 Ti. However, Nvidia's opted
to hide the 8 GB models from reviewers.
So, there is no review embargo for the
RTX 5060. And while the 5060 Ti reviews
do go live today, there will be few, if
any, 8 GB card reviews. Nvidia was
unable to provide a satisfactory or even
logical answer for why reviewers
wouldn't be receiving the 8 GB models
for review. And although they denied
claims that they were attempting to hide
8 GB reviews, we know for a fact they
are. Nvidia told us we were free to
reach out to their partners to get an 8
GB model for review today. But when we
did so, the partners told us they were
under strict instruction from Nvidia not
to send out any 8 GB cards for review.
So in order to review an 8 GB RTX
5060Ti, we have to purchase one when
they eventually go on sale. And we're
not quite sure when that's going to be.
just yet. Now, I'm sure some reviewers,
a reviewer, was able to work with
retailers to get one ahead of time, but
shipping in our region was quite slow
and some brands won't have 8 GB models
in the country until later this week.
And that's at the earliest. Anyway, what
all this boils down to is the simple
fact that Nvidia knows they shouldn't be
releasing GPUs as powerful as a 5060 Ti
with just 8 GB of VRAM in 2025. So to
avoid a barrage of negative content,
they're just not sending them out and
they're making sure no one else does
either. So no reviewers, no one can get
one. The idea here is likely to generate
as much positive RTX 5060Ti 16 GB
content as they can and then push out
the 8 GB models knowing most gamers who
aren't particularly techsavvy will just
end up buying the cheaper 8 GB models
not knowing there's a 16 GB version or
what that even means. So, for now, we
have the 5060 Ti 16 GB to review as this
is all Nvidia's provided us. But of
course, I will be buying an 8 GB card as
soon as possible. As for the specs,
pretty straightforward stuff really.
It's almost a copy and paste of the
previous generation with a few minor
tweaks. Focusing on the 5060 Ti 16 GB as
again that's all we have for review
today. We're looking at a 6% increase in
core count and an insignificant 1%
increase in the core clock speed when
compared to the 4060Ti 16 GB. However,
because the 4060 series only featured a
128 bit wide memory bus with relatively
slow GDDR6 memory, in many instances,
performance was memory limited. This is
where the new 5060Ti should have a big
advantage because although it's limited
to the same 128 bit wide memory bus, the
upgrade to GDDR7 memory has increased
the memory bandwidth by a massive 56%
and this could result in some pretty
large performance gains which I'm very
interested to explore. So, let's get
into the data. Starting with Marvel
Rivals at 1440p, the 5060Ti is
considerably faster than the 4060Ti, and
we're looking at a 20% performance
boost, which placed it alongside the
7800 XT and RTX 4070. Then at 4K, it was
29% faster than the 4060Ti. And again,
that meant similar performance to the
7800 XT and RTX
4070. The performance boost over the
4060Ti at 1440p and Counter-Strike 2 is
quite impressive. a 24% uplift here,
averaging 398 FPS, and that meant the
5060 Ti was roughly on par with the RTX
4070 and
RX970. It does slip a little bit at 4K
in this example, though it's still 25%
faster than the 4060Ti despite being 14%
slower than the
RX970. Next up, we have Star Wars Jedi
Survivor. And at 1440p, the 5060Ti is
only able to match the 7700 XT with 66
FPS, making it 16% faster than the
4060Ti. Then at 4K, we're looking at a
mere 31 FPS, which is just an 11%
increase from the 4060 Ti. And again,
basically the same level of performance
we see from the 7700 XT. Moving on to a
playtail reququum. Again, starting with
the 1440p data, the 5060 Ti is 17%
faster than the 4060 Ti, making it just
6% faster than the 7700 XT. Then at 4K,
it's not really powerful enough to
render at this resolution, though
upscaling will help a lot. But anyway,
we're again looking at 7700 XT light
performance, making the 5060 Ti 23%
faster than the 4060 Ti. The Cyberpunk
2077 results are again pretty typical of
what we've seen so far with the 5060 Ti
matching the RTX 4070 and 7700 XT at
1440p with 79 FPS. Then at 4K, it
actually manages to nudge ahead of those
models, coming in a massive 38% faster
than the 4060 Ti. So clearly the
additional memory bandwidth is helping a
lot here.
The 5060 Ti averaged 66 FPS and Dying
Light 2 Stay Human at 1440p, making it
22% faster than the 4060 Ti and only
slightly slower than the 7800 XT. Then
at 4K, it matched the RTX 4070 with 36
FPS, which was a massive 29% increase
over the 4060 Ti. Oddly though,
performance in Dragon Age: The Valgar
doesn't look all that great at 1440p,
just 7% faster than the 4060Ti and 12%
slower than the RTX
4070. Things get even worse at 4K, not
just because we're looking at a mere 35
fps on average, but also because the
5060Ti was just 6% faster than the 4060
Ti. Spider-Man Remastered saw a more
typical 17% performance improvement for
the 5060 Ti over the 4060 Ti at 1440p,
which actually made it a good bit faster
than the 7800 XT. Then at 4K, it
basically matched the 7800 XT with 73
FPS on average, coming in just 9% slower
than the RTX 4070, but 20% faster than
the 4060Ti.
Nvidia's previous generation 4060Ti was
particularly weak in Hogwarts Legacy.
And here at 1440p, we see that the new
5060Ti is a good bit faster, delivering
20% greater performance, falling just
shy of the RTX 4070 and 7700 XT. That
said, it somehow completely tanks at 4K,
delivering 4060 Ti light performance
with just 42 FPS on average. That's a
mere 5% increase over the previous
model. We're also looking at a 21%
uplift for the 5060Ti over the 4060Ti
and The Last of Us Part One at 1440p,
rendering 70 fps on average. Then at 4K,
the average frame rate dropped to just
35 fps, which is slightly better
performance than you'll see from the
7700 XT and slightly slower than the RTX
3080. The performance improvement in
Star Wars Outlaws is surprisingly small.
This was also the case in Dragon Age:
The Valgard. And what both of these
games have in common is that they use
rateracing. At 1440p, the 5060 Ti was
just 6% faster than the
4060Ti. So, a disappointing result
there. At 4K, the margin does extend to
11%, though we're talking about 18 FPS
versus 20 FPS. And at the end of the
day, we're only looking at 7700 XT like
performance anyway in a game that uses
ray tracing. So, pretty unimpressive.
Starfield appears to be another game
where the RTX 5060Ti falls in a bit of a
heap, outperforming the previous
generation model by a mere 6% margin,
rendering 51 FPS at
1440p. Then at 4K, it's just 10% faster
than the 4060Ti, matching the 7700 XT
with just 32 FPS.
The performance uplift in Delta Force
was also quite small, just 9% at 1440p,
which meant the new 5060 Ti was slightly
slower than the 7700 XT. The margin did
jump back up to 16% at 4K, so a half
decent uplift there, though that still
made it a few frames slower than the
7700 XT. We're looking at a 17% uplift
in God of War Ragnarok when testing at
1440p. And this is once again 7700 XT
like performance.
As we've seen numerous times now, the
5060 Ti scales much better than the
4060Ti at 4K, delivering 27% greater
performance. And this will be in part
due to the new Blackwell architecture,
but mostly due to that additional memory
bandwidth. The Stalker 2 results are
again very typical of what we've seen so
far. A 13% uplift at 1440p for RTX
4070/700 XT live performance. Then at
4K, the 5060 Ti matched the 7700 XT,
making it 19% faster than the 4060
Ti. For some reason, the 5060Ti was
barely any faster than the 4060 Ti in
Call of Duty Black Ops 6 at 1440p,
offering a mere 3% uplift, making it 17%
slower than the 7700 XT. Then at 4K,
we're looking at just a 6% performance
increase over the 4060 Ti. So
performance in Black Ops 6 is extremely
underwhelming. So across the 16 games
tested, the 5060 Ti was on average just
4% faster than the 7700 XT and 10%
slower than the RTX 4070 and 11% slower
than the RTX 3080. It was however 15%
faster than the 4060Ti. So not an
amazing uplift overall, it has to be
said. Then at 4K, it was on average 2%
faster than the 7700 XT, but 11% slower
than the RTX 4070. That said, we're
seeing a more healthy 20% improvement
over the
4060Ti. Though performance wasn't always
great at
4K. Now, for a more in-depth look at ray
tracing performance, we'll start with
Metro Exodus Enhanced. Here, the 5062i
is 25% faster than the 4062i at 1440p.
again delivering RTX 4070 light
performance. The 4K performance though
isn't great. Just 38 FPS, which is a few
frames slower than the RTX 4070 and 7900
XT, but also 23% faster than the 4060
Ti. Now, the Allo Mate 2 results are
interesting because, as we've seen
previously in a few games such as Star
Wars Outlaws and Dragon Age: The
Valgard, both use and were tested with
RA tracing enabled. In those examples,
we saw little to no performance uplift
for the 5060 Ti. And we see that here
once again as it only matched the 4060
Ti with just 30 FPS at 1440p with
upscaling
enabled. So given how bad the upscaled
1440p performance was, it's no surprise
that 4K is out of the question, just 16
fps here. And again, we are using
upscaling.
We're also looking at very weak
performance gains in Cyberpunk 2077,
just 7% faster than the 4060Ti here with
46 FPS on average, which is extremely
disappointing ray tracing performance at
just 1440p with upscaling. Nvidia's
really struggled to or even failed to
deliver a transformative RT experience
to the masses even after all these
years. Again, 4K is simply out of the
question. and the 5060 Ti was good for
just 23 fps and we're not even talking
about native
4K. The Spider-Man remastered ray
tracing performance is much more
impressive though that said the RTX 4060
and 7700 XT were also very acceptable
here. Still, we are looking at a 22%
performance improvement from the 4060Ti
for the 5060 Ti at 1440p with
upscaling. Even 4K upscaled is very
usable. 72 FPS on average, allowing the
5060 Ti to match the 7T0000 JRE and beat
the 4060Ti by a 24% margin. We're
testing Blackmth Wukong using what we
believe to be transformative ray tracing
quality settings. And yet at 1440p with
the aid of upscaling, the new 5060 Ti
was good for just 34 fps, a 17%
improvement over the previous model, but
still very weak performance overall. And
that being the case, you can completely
forget about upscale to 4K, but here are
the results anyway. Just 17 FPS for the
5060 Ti. The Dying Light 2 performance
at 1440p with DLSS upscaling enabled is
okay. 57 FPS on average. It's not
amazing, though. That is the same level
of performance you'll receive from the
Sein and a 14% bump over the 4060 Ti.
And then we're dropping down to just 31
FPS at 4K, again with quality upscaling,
though that was a 24% boost over the
Ti. Another new ray tracing title that
can offer a transformative RT experience
is Indiana Jones and the Great Circle,
but using the required quality settings
for set experience results in a
lackluster 29FPS on average at upscaled
1440p for the 5060 Ti. Again, upscale to
4K is completely out of the question
using these RT settings. Just 18 FPS
here for the 5060
Ti. So, at 1440p across the seven games
tested, the 5060 Ti averaged 49 FPS,
delivering a comparable RT experience to
the new
RX970 and slightly better than the RTX
4070. It was also 14% faster than the
4060 Ti on average. So, very similar
gains to what we're seeing in our mostly
raster based testing. We have the 4K
data, which is why I featured it in the
video, but really the 5060 Ti is nowhere
near powerful enough for upscaled 4K ray
tracing. For that, you really do need
something like an RTX
5080. When it comes to power usage,
there's no surprises with the 5060 Ti.
As we just saw, it's generally around
15% faster than the 4060Ti and
therefore, as expected, it consumed
around 15% more power. It also consumed
around 50 W less than the 7700 XT. So, a
pretty big power saving there and
generally better
performance. Now, on hand for testing,
we have three RTX 5060 Ti 16 GB models,
the MSI Ventus, Asus Tough Gaming, and
Gigabyte Gaming OC. And we'll start by
looking at the performance
characteristics of the MSI card. Under
load for an hour, we saw a peak GPU
temperature of just 64° and a peak
memory temperature of 62°. And to
achieve this, the fan spun at 2500 RPM.
And we saw an average GPU power draw of
142 W with a core frequency of
2,730 MHz. For comparison, the Asus
Tough Gaming model saw a peak GPU
temperature of just 58° and a memory
temperature of 64° at a fan speed of
just 1,000 RPM. So, unsurprisingly, the
much larger Tough Gaming model did run
cooler and quieter. The GPU power
consumption averaged 149 W and the cores
2,800 MHz. That's a 2 and a half%
frequency bump over the MSI model. Then
we have the Gigabyte Gaming OC. And this
model saw a peak GPU temperature of 57°
while the memory hit 60°. So the coolest
operating card of the three, though it
was a bit louder than the ASUS model at
a fan speed of 1,700 RPM. And we saw a
typical power draw of 147 W and a core
frequency of 2,820 MHz. So overall, all
three cards performed very well. Okay,
so now it's time to check out the value
of the 5060 Ti. And we'll start with the
MSRP. And while not an accurate metric
for current market value, it still shows
how much value the 5060Ti should be
offering when compared to past
generations. You can see just how
terrible the 4060Ti 16 GB was, costing
more per frame than parts like the RTX
4070. This means at MSRP the 5060Ti 16
GB would be offering 25% better value
than the 4060Ti 16 GB. So that's pretty
good. However, it's only able to match
the value of the 7800 XT and is
considerably worse value than the 1970
and 9070 XT. So really, this should be
at most a $400 US product. Though having
said that, we know it won't even be
$430. Now, here's how the MSRP of the
5060 Ti 16 GB, because really that's all
we have to go on at this point in time,
stacks up against the current retail
pricing of the models that are still in
stock along with the pricing for the
GeForce 40 and Radeon 7000 series from
midway through 2024. So, I guess what
you could have got or still can if you
have a time machine, if available for
$430 US, even if it was last year, the
5060 Ti 16 GB wouldn't have been amazing
or wouldn't be amazing, only offering
slightly better value than the RTX 4070
Super and still more costly than both
the 7800 XT and 7700 XT. Sadly, however,
this data is likely going to end up
being nonsense as the 5060Ti 16 GB will
sell for over $500, which would make it
worse value than the RTX 4070 and
probably worse value than what you could
have bought the 4060Ti 16 GB for this
time last year. So, that's exciting.
Now, this graph is based on the current
retail pricing here in Australia. So,
all current and instock prices, at least
at the time of making the video, the
5062 is expected to be available at 900
AUD. This is above the recommended
retail price, but this is the to be
expected typical sort of pricing for
this product. And that's based on
information that's been shared with me
ahead of time. And this we'll see it
cost more per frame than even the RTX
5070. basically offering the same value
as the 9070 XT, though of course the
Radeon GPU is significantly more
powerful, so realistically does offer
more value in that sense. Also, an 18%
premium over the
RX970 is disastrous. Sure, the Radeon
GPU costs $150 more, and that's a
reasonable 17% premium, but then you are
getting almost 40% more performance on
average according to our testing. and
it's very usable at resolutions such as
4K. So, it would be hard not to spend
the extra money on the much more
powerful and technically better value
Radeon GPU. At face value, the GeForce
RTX 5060Ti 16 GB seems like a decent
enough product. Granted, it is a very
small performance upgrade over the
previous generation, but there are still
some decent gains to be had at times.
But the gains alone aren't really good
enough to create any real excitement
around this product and Nvidia knows it.
The RTX 5070, for example, that wasn't
really a great success. Therefore, in an
effort to generate some kind of hype,
Nvidia claims to have lowered the MSRP
to $430 US, which does seem pretty good
given that the 16 GB 4060 Ti started at
$500 and then was later dropped to $450.
So, you're getting a further 4% discount
with 15% better performance
overall. At least that's what we've been
led to believe. The performance claims,
sure, but the price, uh, the truth is
the 5060 Ti is unlikely to cost $430 US.
And in fact, I won't be shocked if
pricing ends up comfortably above $500
US. So, while the 5060Ti 16 GB is a
product that I can see myself
recommending at $430
US, I'm going to resist the urge to get
too excited about this particular
release because like so many GPU
releases over the past year, I'm pretty
confident that excitement is going to be
short-lived. So, I'll leave it to future
GPU pricing update videos to make those
recommendations.
It's also worth noting that AMD has the
Radeon RX960 series coming probably next
month, so it might be worth holding off
to see what's on offer there. But
getting back to the 5060 Ti, we do seem
to have at least at this point in time a
better picture of pricing here in
Australia, as availability has been
better than in the US. If the typical
5060Ti 16 GB pricing is around $900
Australian, then the 5060Ti 16 GB is
going to be a real stinker. Offering
worse value than the RTX 5070, and that
model hasn't sold very well at all here,
uh, terribly would be a better way to
put it. So, based on the $430 US MSRP,
the RTX 506Ti seems like a decent enough
product. But we also know better and the
current Australian pricing seems like a
better indicator of where it's going to
stand and that is to say, well, not
terribly well. We've also been using the
RTX 4060 Ti 16 GB as the measuring stick
for how good the 5060 Ti 16 GB is. And
as I noted at the start of our video,
the 4060 Ti wasn't good, improving upon
the 3060 Ti's value by a mere 2 1/2%.
You have to remember as well the 4060Ti
16 GB was just 9% faster than the 3060Ti
and that's a GPU that was released back
in December of 2020 for $400 US. The big
upgrade on offer here though is that
larger 16 GB VRAM buffer and while you
are clearly paying for it with this
generation, 16 GB does make this card
very usable. So the 16 GB 5060 Ti is a
good upgrade from the 3060 Ti. It just
took roughly five years to get here,
which is probably the disappointing part
for a lot of you. This stagnation has
caused some real issues for the GeForce
program in my opinion. For a long time
now, Nvidia has been harping on about
ray tracing, telling gamers how amazing
it is, though with very few examples to
point to, even for RTX 5090 owners. But
for an RTX 5060Ti, there are almost no
truly transformative ray tracing
examples. Nvidia really has failed to
deliver a transformative RT experience
to the masses. Even after all of these
years, and I know it won't shock that
many of you, but the marketing has not
been supported by the results. The RT
experience you can enjoy with a product
like the 5060Ti is very underwhelming.
And let's not even talk about those 8 GB
models. Uh, I will dedicate a video
though to talking about those 8 GB
models as soon as I can get my hands on
one. The problem is, as it has been from
the start for us, Nvidia released the
GeForce 20 series with some really big
promises about stuff like ray tracing
that never came to fruition for that
generation. So, in a way, you were sold
a well, you were definitely sold a lie.
Like, what are we talking about? You
definitely were at this point. And now
all these years later, the experience is
still very poor unless you're willing to
spend over $1,000 US. And even then, you
really only have a handful of examples
that you can point to that are truly
great. In order to get away with those
claims, Nvidia really did need to have
delivered the goods by now. And instead
they've gone the other way in my
opinion. Continually doubling down on
marketing BS, delivering gamers features
that they don't necessarily want. Stuff
like multiframe generation for example,
and then weaponizing it to claim stuff
like the 5060 Ti is twice as fast as the
RTX 4060
Ti. Absolute complete and utter garbage.
It's it's nothing short of a lie. The
GeForce brand really has eroded over
these past few generations to the point
where we're now dealing with failed RT
promises for the masses, fake frames,
and even fake
MSRPs. Does sound a bit harsh, I know,
but it really is the truth. The GeForce
50 series has been shockingly bad and
probably the worst generation I can
recall. Of course, though, Nvidia hardly
cares about GeForce right now, and this
will only become an issue for them if
the AI bubble bursts. For now, they can
just keep making mad money selling
silicon to the AI market, and gamers are
just stuck with the overpriced leftovers
supported by probably the worst drivers
we've seen from Nvidia in maybe forever,
certainly a very long time. So, yeah,
happy days indeed. Anyway, I know that's
a pretty disappointing way to end this
review and some pretty harsh feedback,
but I think it's pretty well warranted
at this point. I don't think too many of
you are going to disagree with those
comments about where GeForce is at and
how Nvidia is proceeding. But anyway, um
yeah, if we'll see what the pricing of
this card ends up like and then we'll
sort of re-evaluate um or we'll we'll
give our real recommendations in an
updated GPU pricing guide probably
midway through next month. We'll see how
things play out. And of course, I have
many alerts out on the 8 GB card. Many
people trying to support us there. So,
we will get one as soon as possible and
then update you guys on all of that.
Yeah, that is going to do it for this
video. If you enjoyed it, give it a
like, subscribe. We also have the join
button and Patreon if you want to get
more Har and Box goodness, give you
access to stuff like our Q&A series,
behind the scenes content, live streams,
and of course the Discord server. So,
yeah, check that out if you're
interested, but if not, that's perfectly
fine. And I would like to thank you for
watching this video. I'm your host,
Steve. See you next time.
[Music]